marianne williamson is here Maryanne
great to see you
everybody all right Marianne I mean
looking into your past I tell you are
actually too interesting to run for
president too many things I want to talk
to you about but first I just want to
say congratulations for being the most
googled thank you from the debate and
everyone wants to talk to you now thank
you
right and I think it's interesting
because people who are just coming to
you through politics that's what they're
good anyway like I'm old enough to
remember you've been around and you're
big you were Oprah's spiritual advisor I
don't know about that but she was very
generous to me that's for sure yeah I
know
so because a lot of your politics does
spring from this former life you had I
guess the life you'll continue if you
don't win is based on well this book
called A Course in Miracles well my
career for the last 35 years I have
given talks based on this set of books
called the Course in Miracles which has
been referred to as a self-study program
of spiritual psychotherapy that sounds
like Scientology how can you know it
just sounds like it I'm not saying it is
just when something is based on one book
that always worries me but it is a book
that is based on universal spiritual
themes it is not a religion it does not
claim any kind of monopoly on truth word
it has no Dogma it has no doctrine it
talks about love and forgiveness and I
think that so many of the people who are
students of the Course in Miracles come
from all religions and even no religions
people like you but you but I read the
walk
[Laughter]
I read that the author of the book Helen
sheckman said she took dictation from
Jesus well there's nothing in the book
maybe she did maybe she felt that way
the book is not trying to get up who
would know better than you did she take
dictation from Jesus or not the book
says nothing about that the book does
not try to get us to believe in God the
book does not try to get us to believe
in Jesus the book tries to get us to
believe in each other the book is about
believing in each other and living with
love for one another which is the
experience of a higher power or God as
people at home we can't argue with that
ok so one thing I like about you in the
debates I've said this before on this
show with only one thing there was a cup
no 1 thing that is about all issues you
always go to the root of things I love
that you know everybody else is talking
surface right and you say what about you
know immigration but let's talk about
why they're coming here but the drug war
in those cars that's why they and health
you know you and I are simpatico on
health I did mention that on the show
last time what you say is what I have
always said we're never gonna fix this
healthcare crisis because we don't ask
what why are people so sick doctors
don't ask you what you eat well our
current politics our current political
establishment what I call yada-yada-yada
politics is based in 20th century
thinking this is now the 21st century
and the 21st century mindset we have a
far more whole person holistic
understanding of things we understand
that there's affect but there's also
cause there's external symptoms but
there's also how people feel what people
think there are underlying forces and
dynamics in people's lives that must be
addressed if we are to transform one
life and all it is a nation is is a
group of individuals so those same
processes those same factors must be
addressed if we're to change the country
so there's a 21st century political
conversation that the old establishment
doesn't seem to understand but what's
most dangerous now doesn't seem to be
open to and that must change or we will
not be Trump and we will not bring forth
a future that we want for and with just
the health issue again
the greed of the pharmaceutical company
yes you know the food companies right
the environment right all the toxicity
in the chemicals this is why people are
so sick you're not gonna fix this unless
you get to that why are they sick well
exactly why do we have so much more
chronic disease than in other countries
and that what you're saying and I
brought that up at both debates you
can't just talk about a health care
system you have to realize it's a
sickness care system right so we have to
address issues of chemical chemical
policies agricultural policies
environmental policies even in economic
policies because the economic anxiety
that's already been referred to causes
such stress we subsidize the wrong foods
why we live on corn like reppuken cows
but then you have to go even deeper than
that cows are not supposed to live on
corn either so I want to ask you about
mental health because this was you know
yes we have to go even deeper than that
though because it's not just the the the
corporate interests of underlie our
health crises but corporate interests
that underlie our dysfunction in every
area so it's not just chemical policies
or agricultural companies it's also the
health insurance companies it's also the
big pharmaceutical companies it's also
the gun manufacturers it's also the
fossil fuel companies and it's also the
defense contractors it's the fact that
our government has stopped being a
government of the people by the people
and for the people and is of those huge
multinational corporate interests by
those youth Montana's right now you're
giving me your stump speech
don't become a pilot did alright so
mental health you gotta do it brewer
Harbor I read this now again I'm with
you on this B and I read this this is
how the New York Times characterized
your basic views and of course it's
presented as kind of a like what what's
this crazy lady saying I agree with
everything mrs. Williams in SS has
criticized the widespread use of
antidepressants I'm down with that they
aren't too much okay suggested that we
that they were to blame that they were
to blame for some celebrities suicides
we don't know but I thought the same
thing
characterized treatment guidelines for
postpartum depression as a way for
pharmaceutical companies to make more
money I don't know a lot about that but
I know pharmaceutical companies are not
above doing anything and called the
distinction between ordinary sadness and
clinical depression artificial I think
that's a bit of a mischaracterization
but you do say that yes we over prime
prescribe these drugs and sadness is a
part of life you don't always need a
pill first isn't that your basic thrust
well absolutely there is a spectrum of
normal human despair someone that you
loved died you went through a divorce
you had a had a bankruptcy or a
financial failure there are all kinds of
severe disappointments in life but
they're not a mental illness and I also
think that we have to deal with the fact
that we're now Attorney General's all
over this country are even now in
dieting executives at big pharmaceutical
companies for what we know are their
role in the opioid crisis so given that
we know about the over prescription of
painkillers and the over manufacturer
and the over sale of opioids I don't
know why we would just assume that in
every other area that Big Pharma is
acting with the purest of intent and
concerned with a common good I have
asked
[Applause]
you